يبدو مشاهدينا ان ملابس المستقبل ستكون
حيه
وذاتيه الاصلاح ولكن كيف يعادل وجد فريق
بحكي بريطانيا ان الخيوط الرفيعه الشبيهه
بالجذور التي تنتجها العديد من الفطريات
يمكن استخدامها كماده قابله للتحلل وقادره
ايضا على اصلاح نفسها قابله للتحلل اوكي
فهمتها بس كيف تصلح نفسها مش عارفين على
كل حال اظهرت الاختبارات ان الماده قادره
على استبدال الثقوب التي تم انشاؤها فيها
ومع القليل من العمل على هذه الفطريات
يمكن ان تكون جلودا رقيقه كبديلا الجلد
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات